يعني
نحن هنا ليس هذه هذه ليست اول مره سنقدم
فيها المساعدات نحن موجودون في سوريا في
جميع المناطق
منذ ولدينا شركاء على الارض
والزملاء الموجود
ويحاولون بقدر الاستطاعه الوصول ولكن يعني
يجب ان نكون ايضا موضعيين ويجب ان نكون
واقعيين هناك عقبات قويه هناك عقبات
الوصول بسبب كل الظروف التي حضرتك ذكرتها
هناك احيانا تمويل ايضا يعني نحن حتى قبل
هذه
الفاجعه كانت لدينا صعوبه في ايصال
المساعدات الشتويه لان المساعدات برنامج
المساعده الشتويه كان يجب ان يصل
لاكثر لاربعه مليون ناجح ولاجئ في سوريا
والمنطقه ولكن
في التمويل وهذا ايضا جزء من المشكلات يجب
ان يكون هناك نهضه في تقديم المساعدات
للسوريين واللاجئين والناجحين لان هذا وقت
اصدار صعب جدا جدا وعلى الجميع مساندتهم
نحن دائما نقول الاحتياجات الانسانيه يجب
ان تكون بعيدا عن السياسه وهذه اللحظه
بالذات هي اللحظه التي يجب ان نضع السياسه
جانبا ونكفر جهودنا لتلبيه احتياجاتهم
الانسانيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر من عمان رولا
الامين المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه
للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا